monsters
it's great found at the seaside you can
swim make sand castles and have a
picture
foreign
but before you go home remember to put
your all your rubbish in the bin or take
it home with you
foreign
halfway around the world even as far as
the North Pole
thank you
Sears are curious and playful animals
who often get tangled up with people's
rubbish
sea turtles often think that carrier
bags are jellyfish their favorite food
they end up getting caught inside
it's not just big sea and animals that
are affected by rubbish small bits of
plastic can be swallowed by other
creatures
foreign
thank you
promise
no more rubbish
foreign
thank you
plastic bags take 10 to 20 years to
break down
to 200 years to break down
450 years to break down
a plastic drink bottle takes
later
in Canon takes 18 to 200 years to break
down